earlier this week the governor urged
nevadans to stay at home
as coronavirus cases do surge nationwide
and since then several states on the
west coast have implemented travel
advisories for anyone who might be
heading out of state
but it's not stopping some from actually
visiting las vegas
sasha loftus live on the strip tonight
with more on this
sasha denise and brian we saw
quite a few tourists out and about
tonight they say they feel safe coming
here to the valley as long as everyone
follows the rules
but i also spoke with a local expert who
said that traveling of any kind right
now
has the potential to put everyone at
risk
as the coronavirus pandemic rages on
tourism is still alive and well here in
las vegas
here i i think a little bit of a mix
i see people wearing masks and i see
people not wearing masks
if you don't have to go out don't go out
governor siselek has asked all southern
nevadans to stay home
and curb a record case spike but he says
visitors are still welcome they
certainly should come because those are
protecting our jobs but when they come
here and they're staying in one of our
properties
they need to wear a mask unlv assistant
public health professor brian labis
tells me traveling ramps up
everyone's risk especially if some
aren't going with necessary guidelines
if people aren't following the steps
they need to take to protect others
everyone's risk goes up not just the
other tourists
but the people that are working in the
casinos see at increased risk as well
he says anyone taking a trip should
consider the potential consequences
everybody needs to do their part and
maintain social distancing wear masks
and do what you can
to protect yourself and others when you
visit las vegas that's why the tourists
we spoke with say it's important to take
precautions
and keep our city open and healthy it's
very good so you have to go
and see things but
safe safely
i did reach out to the governor's office
to see if the state would be
implementing any kind of travel
restrictions here in nevada since the
governor's press conference
earlier this week i have not yet heard
back
reporting live on the las vegas strip
sasha loftis 8 news now